hi in this video I am going to talk
about transport of lipoproteins so what
are the lipoproteins
as the name suggests lipoproteins are
protein plus lipids so how many type of
lipoproteins there are in our body so
there are mainly four type of
lipoproteins firstly we have something
called chylomicron we have something
called VLDL we have LDL and another
thing we have we call it HDL these are
the type of
lipoproteins that we have in our body so
as you can see these dark blue lines and
the light blue lines represent the
protein and lipid content in the in
these lipoproteins so as in the
chylomicron is concerned chylomicron the
main part is actually the lipid portion
and very less amount of protein is
present in the chylomicron these VLDL
have a little bit more amount of protein
but still it has a very less amount of
the protein and LDL the protein amount
is a little bit more and HDL the protein
amount is almost 50/50
so these HDL is also called a PO a
family of lipoprotein and these three
called a po b family of lipoprotein or
these threes these three things
especially the LDL is known as
atherogenic lipoprotein why we would see
in a moment so here is a man I've taken
a diet full of fat and after taking the
diet full of fat the fat would be
digested with the help of pancreatic
lipase the fat would be broken down
down the triglyceride would be broken
down to one of this ride then the in
sequential manner like diacylglycerol
then to Monacelli glycerol then to free
fatty acids and here it's the small
intestine I am drawing the small
intestine of the man and just if we zoom
into the small intestine portion if we
zoom into the small intestine portion of
the man what we have here is the luminal
cells the endothelial cells of the lumen
which have a lot of villi so let's see
how these are free fatty acids form
chylomicron inside these luminal
endothelial cells these are end or
failure cells first what happens the
free fatty acids get inside the free
fatty acid that are less than 12 carbon
could be directly secreted into the
bloodstream and the free fatty acids
that are a little bit large are not
directly or secreted into the
bloodstream
instead the free fatty acid with the
triglycerides I am representing it as TG
and with cholesterol representing as CH
l and some phospholipids together form
something called chylomicron so
chylomicron is nothing but a blob of
lipid and some amount of protein inside
it so when this blob of lipid that means
that kind of micron which is full of
triglyceride cholesterol
some amount of phospholipid is secreted
into the blood some proteins get
associated with this chylomicron so what
are these proteins these proteins are a
poor B family of like OB family of
proteins so most popular one is Apple B
48
other proteins are like c2 and another
protein is called
e so all these are proteins and these
triglycerides and cholesterol forms this
chylomicron just representing
chylomicron has a small blob and this
chylomicron will do what chylomicron
would actually migrate through the blood
vessel and some course of time the kind
of micron would actually encounter the
adipose tissue adipose tissue here in
the adipose tissue what will happen the
chylomicron have situ the chylomicron
have E and also the Apple B 48 c2 will
track this chylomicron particle into
these adipose tissue and here we have
LPL the lipoprotein lipase the capital
capillary endothelial lipase these LPL
will do what it will break down
cholesterol and form free fatty acids
and free fatty acids it's stored into
the adipose tissue
thus the fat we have taken in our diet
is some amount of that fat is stored in
the adipose tissue now what happened the
thing that is taken by the adipose
tissue after taking by the adipose
tissue it still have the b48 its have
these a PO e but it doesn't have the c2
so this is known as chylomicron remnant
so this chylomicron remnants trim and
somewhere around when it reaches the
liver it would be taken up by the liver
so this was the exogenous metabolism and
transport of chylomicron so here the
chylomicron would be taken by the liver
why it would be taken
it has Apple II receptor and Apple II
receptor would actually take the
chylomicron in and it will break down
the chylomicron and what happens lever
actually also can secrete another type
of lipoprotein which contain a poby 100
now let me tell you that Apple be 100
and Apple B 48 which are respectively
found in this particular is called VLDL
very low density lipoprotein and this F
of B 4 th and Apple B 10 are actually
isoforms these are generated due to
alternative splicing and this also have
C 2 this also have E now it have plenty
of cholesterol and triglyceride inside
it so these are VLDL one secreted by the
liver or will also get inside the
capillaries and with in the capillaries
it will migrate around the whole body
and sometime these VLDL also may
encounter a fatty tissue that means the
adipose tissue as it has a c2 receptor
as it has our c2 receptor it would be
attracted it as it has a c2 receptor it
would be attracted towards the LPL the
lipoprotein lipase and it's free fatty
acid would be taken up by the adipose
tissue
now what happens these VLDL would not
remain as we LDL now it's try to write
amount is less so it has less
triglyceride a lot of cholesterol it
still has the be 100 and it has the
Apple II lipoprotein but don't have the
C 2 because C 2 is lost during the
tracking into the LPL so this new type
of particle is called as intermediate
density lipoprotein IDL or also known as
VLDL remnant
now this IDL what happened this ideal
could get into the bloodstream and
migrate all around the body and during a
course of time when it encounters liver
this ideal particle it can also be taken
up by the liver as the lever HAP has
these Apple II kind of receptor or
another fit of this ideal is ideal could
be converted into another new species
this species is called
the LDL which has a lot of cholesterol a
lot of cholesterol LDL only has its
upper be 100 and allele has a PO e so
what happens what happens these LDL 50%
of the LDL 50% of the LDL is taken by
the lever via the process called
receptor mediated endocytosis
clattering coated endocytosis and 50% of
the LDL 50% of the LDL is released into
the bloodstream so here we have LDL
released inside our bloodstream and LDL
is circulating around the blood stream
LDL is also known as bad cholesterol and
in a moment we will see why it is called
as bad cholesterol so here what happens
LDL which is a some arterial space so
LDL has a be 100 a lot of cholesterol it
has as it has a lot of cholesterol it
can deposit some amount of cholesterol
over here in the endothelial lining and
a plaque could build up a plaque could
build up ultimately it would lead to
formation of the atherogenic plaques and
ultimately the atherosclerosis
so this cholesterol is pretty bad
I mean cholesterol is important because
cholesterol is required for steroid
hormone biosynthesis
all our steroid hormone is
biosynthesized from cholesterol but the
too much circulatory level of LDL that
means the bad cholesterol is harmful for
us because it is atherogenic because the
cholesterol content could be deposited
on the endothelial linings and it could
build a pup block so this was our
cholesterol transport in a forward
direction another thing is that when
this liver is taking up chylomicron or
taking up IDL with this cholesterol or
triglycerides it is building bile salts
it can biosynthesize phospholipids and
from glycerol it can biosynthesize
glucose also so this is how these things
are getting utilized in the liver and
here we would see another thing which we
call the reverse cholesterol transport
and the key player in the reverse
cholesterol transport is a new type of
lipoprotein which have a very less
amount of lipid inside it but a lot of
protein inside we call these thing as
HDL high density lipoprotein so it has
Apple lipoprotein a1 and it is also
called as a garbage truck so we can
think about the LDL as a garbage truck
which is depositing lot of garbage that
means the cholesterol into the
endothelial lining and thus it's a
plaque is building up so these
apolipoprotein one continuing particles
that means the HDL will come here and
these HDL will come here and age as HDL
is quite empty and it doesn't have that
much amount of lipid inside it it will
take up these deposited blocks so HDL is
good in one sense because HDL actually
acts as a scavenger it's anti
atherogenic so LDL
is atherogenic but HDL is anti-allergic
so this HDL will migrate all around the
body and HDL will take up the excess
amount of cholesterol where it will take
it up to gonads that means testes or
ovary so in testes the interstitial
cells will produce that testosterone
because cholesterol is a precursor of
those steroid hormones and also in the
ovary it can form the sturgeon and
progesterone and also it can take the
cholesterol to adrenal cortex so all at
the adrenal cortex hormones cortisol
cortisone these are all steroid hormones
so they need actually their precursor or
precursor cholesterol for synthesis so
in this organ cholesterol would be
converted into steroid hormones and that
this is how the whole transport of the
lipoproteins in our body is regulated so
now if we zoom into this section where
how the liver is up taking the LDL
particles or the veal other ideal
particles and what is the exact
mechanism of it so this whole diagram is
a hypothetical diagram it's obstruct
trigram so we don't have these much big
capillaries but for better understanding
I have drawn the capillaries in big and
these endothelial cells so so and also
the liver doesn't have receptors like
these reliever hepatocytes the cells in
the liver have these kind of receptors
so here I'm drawing a surface view of a
hepatocytes cell liver hepatocytes so in
this liberal rapid side it has LDL
receptor yeah it does have a lot of
receptor for LDL or all these type of
lipoprotein particles so when the
lipoprotein particles comes in
it gets bind to this receptor
and on the inside of the cell that means
in the cytoplasmic side adapter proteins
get associated with it on the adapter
proteins a new coat called the
clattering coat is actually build up
this clattering coat is build up clapton
is a of just a jacket type of thing
which coats this whole indentation and
here you can see the lipoprotein
particle say for instance LDL with its
LDL receptor it's totally the membrane
is imaginated and now what happened a
particular protein called the dynamin
will come into play and dynamic will
pinch this indentation and close it so
ultimately what will happen a full
vesicle containing LDL and it's LDL
receptor coated by clattering is
released into the cytoplasmic side and
now what happened the LDL would be
degraded and utilized and the vesicle
containing only receptor would be
recycled back to the cell surface so
that more LDL particle could talk into
the receptor and get inside so this was
a basic cell biology mechanism by which
receptor mediated endocytosis could take
up LDL particles this same a basic
pathway also is valid for IDL or other
like protein pathways so as per summary
which is which is important that these
Applebee containing lipoprotein
especially the app will be 100
containing lipoprotein LDL is actually
the bad cholesterol because it can be
deposited onto the artery as we have
seen and it can form our after genic
block that is why it's quite harmful
hope you enjoyed you have understand
this thing please like and subscribe
thank you